we are sure you all know about peek but
did you know that there are actually
other cart titan users in the show well
don't worry if you didn't know that
because in today's video we will be
explaining all cart titan users in
attack on titan pete grew up in the
liberio internment zone in marley she
joined the warrior program as soon as
she was eligible so she could provide
proper medical care for her father after
performing well enough to be selected to
inherit one of them are land titans she
was chosen to be the next cart titan in
her titan form pique is only 4 meters
tall and usually walks on all fours her
torso is long and flat allowing for
materials to be easily packed onto her
back its long face allows for custom
armor and machine guns to be strapped to
it this is standard wear for the kart
titan when it is an action five years
into the paradise island operation peak
journeys to paradise island with zeke
yeager she is seen in their titan form
behind zeke as he screams and turns all
of the villagers of rigako into titans
they both later join reiner and bertolt
as the survey corps go on an expedition
to reclaim shigan china district pete
keeps watch for their movement overnight
upon seeing the advancing soldiers she
returns to the ruins of shigan china and
informs zeke reiner and bertolt of their
approach as the battle begins she stays
with beast titan all the time because
the kart titan has much lower defenses
than the other nine titans and will be
taken down by a critical or severe blow
she provides zeke with rocks to crush
and throw at the soldiers and keeps
brittles hidden in a barrel atop her
back as a plan b against the survey car
the soldiers choose to engage in a
suicidal charge against the beast titan
in order to buy time for captain levi to
move in for a counter attack as zeke
decimates them he is quickly caught off
guard and defeated by levi before zeke
can be captured pete comes to his rescue
and carries his injured human body away
they retreat to shiganshina district but
only managed to rescue reiner as the
survey corps already defeated bertolt
four years later peak's cart titan can
be seen at the battle of fort slava at
the climax of the war between marley and
the mid-east allied forces once
anti-titan artillery is destroyed both
her and porco engage enemy forces after
defeating the enemy at fort slava the
four-year-long war between marley and
mid-east ends when the survey corps
launched an attack on marley pique and
galliard are led into an empty building
where they both get trapped soon after
escaping they both join the battle peak
stumbles off the roof of the building
and falls after being struck by a
barrage of thunderspears she is
momentarily saved by the sudden
intervention of falco who shields her
from jean after the battle during an
emergency meeting peak theorizes that
zeke jaeger has been planning his raid
with a team of co-conspirators from
inside the marlene military and they
decide to launch a surprise attack
immediately peak infiltrates paradise
island in order to gain information
after galliard's failed attempt to
capture aaron peake falls off the roof
and transforms equipped with an
anti-titan artillery cannon pique
declares that they cannot allow aaron
and zeke to come into contact with each
other after being attacked by enemy
soldiers pique exits her titan form and
hides in the steam of her titan's
decaying body making it look as though
she has been killed afterwards macca
flands a direct hit on zeke's beast
titan knocking him off the wall aaron
makes contact with zeke to start the
rumbling and peek grips the wall as it
begins to disintegrate beneath her peek
and maggoth later agree to join forces
with the survey corps to stop aaron pika
sent to scout paradises dox to see if it
will be safe for the group to follow
aaron but when she returns she reveals
that the jaegers have occupied the docks
and are keeping azumabitos hostages she
uses her titan form to transport the
members of their group who are unable to
fight after leaving the non-combatants
on a boat in the harbor she joins her
comrades in a fight against jaegers they
manage to escape and use the flying boat
to get close to aaron pete grabs the
explosives and drags them out of the
boat with her transforming midair pique
transports the explosives into titan's
mouth while her comrades engage the
beast titan pique tries to rush to his
nape on her own and use the explosives
to kill him she manages to set the
explosives around aaron's snape but
before she can set them off she gets
impaled by warhammer titan peak's
regeneration abilities reach their limit
and leave her unable to heal her
injuries requiring gene to return and
save her while we all know and love
everything about peak we don't get to
learn much about other kart titans
throughout history but we do see some in
the battle of heaven and earth when all
the past titan shifters are summoned by
aaron and ymir the first titan we are
introduced to is okapi kart titan it
catches armon off guard and eats them it
has okapi head but the rest of the body
looks quite normal unlike the nexcart
titan we're going to show you this titan
looks absolutely amazing there is a lot
of speculation about whether it is a
beast cart or even a jaw titan but the
way this titan walks using all four legs
as well as the look of its jaws has
convinced us that this is most likely a
cart titan it has a very strange
appearance it seems to be a mixture of
human and crocodile in the chapter 135
we can also catch a wolf-like cart titan
in the background our artist did an
excellent job of drawing him so that you
could see better how it looks like we
also get a glimpse of the first ever
kart titan in the chapter about ymir
fritz's past the first ever kart titan
looked very similar to peak's cart titan
it had a normal titan body and the only
clear difference to peaks titan is the
horse-shaped head click on this video to
learn more about all female titans in
attack on titan why are you still here
click it